A couple years ago, a guy named Lanail Hudson-- Lanail Thaddeus Hudson, actually-- goes to a government office in Jacksonville, Florida to get a new Florida state ID, and they ask him to wait. And then they call out a state trooper, because a man in Miami with the exact same name, Lanail Thaddeus Hudson, had gone to the authorities and flagged the name. Said there had been identity theft. Said, somebody's got a fake driver's license under this name.
几年前，一个叫拉奈尔·哈德森（Lanail Hudson）的人——确切地说是拉奈尔·萨迪斯·哈德森（Lanail Thaddeus Hudson）——前往佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔的一个政府办公室申请新的州身份证，他们让他先等等。随后他们叫来了一名州警，因为迈阿密有一个名字完全相同的人，也叫拉奈尔·萨迪斯·哈德森，他曾向当局报案并标记了这个名字。他说自己遭遇了身份盗窃，说有人冒用他的名字办了假驾照。
So the trooper shows up, and he's got to figure out what's going on. And the guy walks up to him in the lobby and says, well, maybe we can straighten this out now. Great. So the trooper asks the guy for any proof of who he is. Here's the trooper, Richard Blanco.
于是警察赶到了，他必须弄清楚到底是怎么回事。那个人在大厅走过来对他说，好吧，也许我们现在可以把这件事解决清楚。太好了。于是警察要求那个人出示身份证明。这就是那位警官，理查德·布兰科（Richard Blanco）。
And he opens the backpack, and he starts pulling out all these identifications. Just numerous IDs. The passport, social security card, 20 to 30 pieces of identification on him.
他打开背包，开始掏出各种各样的身份证件。真的是数不胜数的证件。护照、社会保障卡，他身上有20到30份身份证件。
There's a government-issued ID that lets him walk around the port in Jacksonville unescorted. There are two naval IDs that allow him onto Navy vessels. There's a birth certificate.
还有一张政府签发的身份证，允许他在杰克逊维尔港口自由出入，无需陪同。还有两张海军证件，允许他进入海军舰艇。还有一张出生证明。
You know, he's slinging all these identifications on the desk. This is me. This is who I am. These documents, these IDs depicted his photograph. So then I had a little doubt in my mind.
你知道，他把这些身份证件统统甩在桌子上。这就是我。这就是我的身份。这些文件、这些身份证件上都有他的照片。所以我心里产生了一点怀疑。
Your doubt meaning what?
你的怀疑是指什么？
This could be the true Lanail Hudson. He could be the victim.
他可能是真正的拉奈尔·哈德森。他可能是受害者。
So he fingerprints the guy and runs it through the system, and sure enough, the fingerprints match the fingerprints on file for Lanail Hudson. Whoever this is standing in front of them has been arrested all the way back in 1989 as Lanail Hudson. He's actually served in prison as Lanail Hudson.
于是他采集了那个人的指纹并将其输入系统，果然，指纹与档案中拉奈尔·哈德森的指纹相符。不管现在站在他们面前的人是谁，他早在1989年就以拉奈尔·哈德森的身份被捕过。他甚至曾以拉奈尔·哈德森的身份入狱服刑。
But then Trooper Blanco gets the other Lanail Hudson on the phone-- the guy in Miami. That Lanail Hudson turns out to be a corrections officer down in Dade County, and that Lanail Hudson said that ever since his wallet was stolen back in 1989 with his driver's license and his social security card inside, he'd had problems. He tells them--
但随后布兰科警官联系上了迈阿密的那位拉奈尔·哈德森。那个拉奈尔·哈德森原来是戴德县的一名管教人员，他说自从1989年钱包被偷，里面装着驾照和社会保障卡后，他就一直遇到麻烦。他告诉他们——
This guy's taken my identity. He's lived in my identity for 23 years, since 1989. He's caused me all kind of grief. My driver's license is suspended.
这家伙窃取了我的身份。他以我的身份生活了23年，从1989年开始。他给我带来了各种痛苦。我的驾照被吊销了。
He's cashed checks in my name. He has children in my name. On and on.
他以我的名义兑现支票。他以我的名义生儿育女。诸如此类。
At this point, Trooper Blanco strongly suspected the guy standing in front of him in Jacksonville was probably a fake, living under a stolen name. But vexingly, the guy would not admit this, even after he was arrested. At his job, with his wife and kids-- he had an 8-year-old and a 15-year-old at the time-- everybody knew him as Lanail Hudson. In fact, when this went to trial, the guy from Jacksonville still insisted he was Lanail Hudson.
此时，布兰科警官强烈怀疑站在他面前的这个杰克逊维尔人是个冒牌货，一直生活在被盗的身份下。但令人恼火的是，即使在被捕后，那个人也拒不承认。在他的工作中，在妻子和孩子——当时他有一个8岁和一个15岁的孩子——面前，每个人都认识他为拉奈尔·哈德森。事实上，当案件开庭审理时，那个杰克逊维尔人仍然坚称自己就是拉奈尔·哈德森。
His version was that he was Lanail Hudson, and that's all he's ever known himself to be is Lanail Hudson.
他的版本是，他就是拉奈尔·哈德森，他所知道的自己一直就是拉奈尔·哈德森。
And in his version of the story, the other guy is the criminal.
而在他的故事版本中，另一个人才是罪犯。
No, no. He didn't accuse the other guy of being a criminal. He just insisted that he was the real Lanail Hudson. Today, we still don't know who he is, and he's been incarcerated since September 30, 2011.
不，不。他并没有指责另一个人是罪犯。他只是坚称自己才是真正的拉奈尔·哈德森。今天，我们仍然不知道他是谁，他自2011年9月30日起一直被监禁。
Well, today on our radio show, It Says So Right Here. We have stories where what is written on official papers in black and white can determine the rest of your life. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
那么，今天我们的广播节目叫《白纸黑字》（It Says So Right Here）。我们讲述的故事里，官方文件上白纸黑字写着的内容可能会决定你余下的人生。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
And this case right here is a good case in point about that. After his trial, the man from Jacksonville-- he could no longer be Lanail Hudson, right? All of his IDs, his birth certificate-- all of that stuff was seized by the government. He became basically a man with no paper trail at all. No documentation.
而这个案例就是很好的例子。审判结束后，那个来自杰克逊维尔的人——他不能再是拉奈尔·哈德森了，对吧？他所有的身份证件、出生证明——所有这些东西都被政府没收了。他基本上成了一个没有任何记录的人。没有文件。
He's like a man without a country. He had no identity. So, who was he?
他就像一个没有国家的人。他没有身份。那么，他是谁？
Well, we found his wife Rosemary, and she told us that she believes him when he says that Lanail Hudson is the only name he's ever known. She's always known him that way, since 1996. Has never met his family, says he rarely talks about his past.
好吧，我们找到了他的妻子罗斯玛丽（Rosemary），她说当他说拉奈尔·哈德森是他唯一知道的名字时，她相信他。自从1996年以来，她一直这样认识他。她从未见过他的家人，说他很少谈论自己的过去。
When they had kids, she said, she suggested that he might take the kids down from Jacksonville to Miami, where he used to live, to meet his people, and he told her, no. It's too much heartache down there. But she didn't know the details. Trooper Blanco, meanwhile, says there is one clue about what could be his real name.
她说，当他们有了孩子，她曾建议他带着孩子们从杰克逊维尔回他以前住过的迈阿密去见见他的亲人，但他告诉她，不行。那里有太多的心碎。但她不知道具体细节。与此同时，布兰科警官说，关于他真实姓名的一个线索。
There's a good possibility that it was Leroy Mayer or Meyer.
很有可能他叫勒罗伊·梅耶（Leroy Mayer）或梅耶尔（Meyer）。
Those names show up on police paperwork on September 29, 1989, when he was arrested for four charges, including attempted murder and aggravated battery. He's identified as Lanail Hudson in those police reports, but the paperwork also says that he sometimes goes by the name of Leroy Meyers or Leroy Mayers, and his nickname today is Leroy. That's the name his wife calls him. During his trial, he explained that this way.
这些名字出现在1989年9月29日的警方文书中，当时他因包括谋杀未遂和严重攻击在内的四项罪名被捕。他在这些警务报告中被标识为拉奈尔·哈德森，但文书上也提到他有时使用勒罗伊·迈尔斯（Leroy Meyers）或勒罗伊·梅耶尔（Leroy Mayers）的名字，他现在的昵称是勒罗伊。这就是他妻子叫他的名字。在审判期间，他这样解释。
He says, well, when I was a young man, I got involved in a fight, and I licked the guy pretty good. I whipped him. And when I got done, all my friends call me Bad, Bad Leroy.
他说，嗯，当我还是个年轻人的时候，我卷入了一场打斗，我把那个家伙修理得很惨。我揍了他。等我做完这一切，我所有的朋友都叫我“坏坏的勒罗伊”。
Like the Jim Croce song? "Bad, Bad Leroy Brown"?
就像吉姆·克罗齐（Jim Croce）的那首歌？《坏坏的勒罗伊·布朗》（Bad, Bad Leroy Brown）？
[LAUGHING] Yeah.
[大笑] 是的。
And what's your read on this? Like, what do you think is his real story?
你对此怎么看？比如，你认为他真实的故事是什么？
You know, I don't have proof, but I think he's a foreign national. He could be wanted for a crime, could be a fugitive from his country. Even his wife thought he was from another country, but I couldn't prove that he was from another country, so he can't be deported unless you have proof.
你知道，我没有证据，但我认为他是个外籍人士。他可能因某项罪行被通缉，可能是他国家的逃犯。甚至他的妻子也认为他来自另一个国家，但我无法证明他来自另一个国家，所以除非你有证据，否则他无法被驱逐出境。
And when you run Leroy Meyer or Leroy Mayer-- when you run down who that might be, do you see someone of his age with a criminal record or anything like that?
当你查勒罗伊·梅耶或勒罗伊·梅耶尔时——当你追查那可能是谁时，你有没有看到和他年龄相仿且有犯罪记录的人，或者类似的情况？
Nothing came back to Leroy Meyer or Mayer. We could find nothing. He went to prison as John Doe, so he never told us who he was.
勒罗伊·梅耶或梅耶尔的记录一无所获。我们什么也查不到。他以“无名氏”（John Doe）的身份入狱，所以他从未告诉我们他是谁。
And the real trick is once he's released from his 10-year sentence, who's he going to be when he gets out of jail or out of prison? That was a concern of the judge. Who will you be when you're released from prison? What will be your identity?
真正的难题是，当他服完10年刑期获释后，他出狱时会是谁呢？那是法官关心的问题。当你出狱时，你会是谁？你的身份会是什么？
You think if I ran him down now and asked him, he would still insist that he's Lanail?
你认为如果我现在去追踪他并问他，他还会坚称自己是拉奈尔吗？
You know what? I'd like to invite you to do that. I'd like to invite you to go and interview him and see if he'd grant an interview, and see what he would say.
你知道吗？我想邀请你去这么做。我想邀请你去采访他，看看他是否愿意接受采访，看看他会说什么。
Hello?
喂？
Yes, hi. Is this John Doe?
你好。请问是“无名氏”先生吗？
Um, yes. I guess according to the state, I am.
嗯，是的。我想根据国家的说法，我是。
I reached the man that I suppose I'm going to call John Doe at the Federal Correctional Institution in Jesup, Georgia. I asked him what his real name was, the one he was born to.
我联系上了那位我想称之为“无名氏”的人，他在佐治亚州杰瑟普（Jesup）的联邦惩教所。我问他他的真实姓名是什么，那个他出生时就拥有的名字。
Lanail Hudson, and this is the only name I've ever had, the only name I've ever known. I'm dubbed John Doe at this point. I hate when people call me. They don't have the decency to say, well, call me Mr. Doe. John Doe. To me, it represents a nobody, and this seems unreal.
拉奈尔·哈德森，这是我唯一拥有的名字，也是我唯一知道的名字。我现在被称作“无名氏”。我讨厌别人这样叫我。他们连礼貌都没有，怎么说呢，叫我多伊（Doe）先生吧。无名氏。对我来说，这代表什么都不是，而且这看起来很不真实。
Now, the other Lanail Hudson, the man in Miami, he has family members. He has school records from when he was a little boy. If this was your name, why not bring those to your trial to prove it?
那么，另一位拉奈尔·哈德森，迈阿密的那个男人，他有家人。他有小时候的学校记录。如果这是你的名字，为什么不把这些带到法庭上作为证明呢？
I couldn't really-- you know, I didn't have a case. He had a mother that came in and said, this is my son, and a dad that said that. And I had no one to say that, and I think that was the turning point. I don't know who my parents are. I don't know if I have any siblings.
我真的不能——你知道，我没有案子。他有一位母亲进来，说“这是我的儿子”，还有一位父亲也这么说。而我没有任何人能这么说，我认为那是转折点。我不知道我的父母是谁。我不知道我是否有兄弟姐妹。
At his trial, he said he was homeschooled. That's why there were no school records. He said he was raised by a woman who's now deceased named Gertrude Hudson, who told him when he was 12 that she wasn't his real mom. And he said in court, and also on our phone call, that all the other paperwork and photos from his childhood were burned by a girlfriend in 1985 after they had a fight.
在审判时，他说他是居家自学的。这就是为什么没有学校记录的原因。他说他是由一位名叫格特鲁德·哈德森（Gertrude Hudson）的已故女性抚养长大的，当他12岁时，她告诉他，她不是他的亲生母亲。他在法庭上，以及在我们的电话中，都说他童年时期所有其他的文书和照片都在1985年与女朋友吵架后被烧毁了。
And that was the last time that I really had anything really tangible to reflect of my past. I still don't have any of those things.
那是我最后一次拥有任何能够反映我过去的有形东西。我仍然没有任何那些东西。
Can you see how when the prosecution looks at that, they say, well, that looks very convenient. That looks very suspicious.
你能明白当检方看到这一点时，他们会说，嗯，这看起来非常巧合。这看起来非常可疑。
Well, I don't know how it would. I'm telling the truth as it is, what had happened. My perception of how it looked didn't conceive in my mind. I'm just explaining what had happened in my past.
嗯，我不知道怎么会那样。我在讲述事实，发生了什么就是什么。关于它看起来如何，我的感知并没有在我的脑海中形成概念。我只是在解释我的过去发生了什么。
I came out of that conversation still wondering who he was. So here at our radio show, we set out on a search. We called the church where he said he'd been baptized in Miami. Found nothing. Looked for the woman who he said burned his stuff in 1985. Zilch on that one, too.
那次谈话结束后，我仍然想知道他是谁。所以我们的广播节目开始了一项搜索。我们给他说的他在迈阿密接受洗礼的教堂打了电话。一无所获。寻找他说的1985年烧毁他东西的那个女人。在那边也是一无所获。
Then we saw in his police records that the attempted murder and a bunch of other incidents in 1989 all happened at one house. And it named one of the people who lived there, and we found her.
然后我们在他的警方记录中看到，1989年的谋杀未遂和其他一些事件都发生在同一所房子里。报告里提到了住在那里的人之一，我们找到了她。
He used to date my sister, but she's dead now. Used to date my sister.
他以前和我姐姐约会，但她现在去世了。以前和我姐姐约会。
This is Martha Rolle. She says she knew him for a year, year and a half. Did you ever hear the name Lanail Hudson? Did he ever call himself Lanail Hudson?
这是玛莎·罗尔（Martha Rolle）。她说她认识他一年半左右。你有没有听说过拉奈尔·哈德森这个名字？他有没有自称过拉奈尔·哈德森？
No. I don't remember that.
不。我不记得有这回事。
What name did you know him by?
你认识他时，他叫什么名字？
Leroy. Leroy May-- Meyers. I don't know which one it is, but Leroy was Mayers. I knew him by that. I don't know any other name.
勒罗伊。勒罗伊·梅——迈尔斯。我不知道是哪一个，但勒罗伊是梅耶尔斯（Mayers）。我认识他时他叫这个名字。我不知道其他任何名字。
And where was he from?
他来自哪里？
I don't know. I think he was from some kind of island. I don't know if it's Barbados, or somewhere, but he's not from here. He's not from here. He had an accent.
我不知道。我想他来自某种岛屿。我不知道是巴巴多斯还是什么地方，但他不是本地人。他不是本地人。他有口音。
I have to say, 10 years later, his accent's pretty faint. He's gotten rid of his accent.
我得说，10年后，他的口音很淡了。他已经去掉了口音。
Oh, he has?
哦，是吗？
Mostly, yeah.
基本上是的。
Oh my goodness. He sounded to me almost like Jamaican, but not Jamaican.
哦，天哪。在我听来，他几乎像是牙买加人，但不完全是牙买加人。
[INAUDIBLE] Leroy, he was from Trinidad. That's where he said he was from, Trinidad.
[听不清] 勒罗伊，他来自特立尼达。那是他说他来自的地方，特立尼达。
This is Martha's brother, Jonathan Marshall. He also never heard Leroy use the name Lanail Hudson.
这是玛莎的兄弟，乔纳森·马歇尔（Jonathan Marshall）。他也从未听过勒罗伊使用拉奈尔·哈德森这个名字。
I used to talk to him all the time. He was staying at the church right in the back of my house. He used to go with my sister, and him and my sister used to fight a lot. My sister was on drugs and everything, and we all tried to tell him not to deal with my sister, because she was HIV-positive and everything like that. He really wasn't a bad guy.
我过去经常和他聊天。他住在就在我房子后面的教堂里。他过去常和我姐姐交往，他和我的姐姐经常吵架。我姐姐有吸毒等等问题，我们都试图告诉他不要和我的姐姐来往，因为她有HIV阳性什么的。他真的不是一个坏家伙。
My sister hit him in the top of the head one time with a clawed hammer and busted his head open. I took him out to the hospital, and he laid his head all on my shoulder, and we were just crying and all that type of stuff, and I just was constantly telling him to leave the girl alone. But he wouldn't do it.
我姐姐有一次用羊角锤砸了他的头顶，把他的头打破了。我把他带到医院，他把头靠在我的肩膀上，我们当时只是在哭之类的，我一直在告诉他离那个女孩远点。但他就是不肯。
Two weeks after his sister hit Leroy with a hammer, after she told him not to come around anymore, Leroy was lurking outside the house looking in the windows, and Jonathan went outside to shoo him away, and Leroy shot him. Four or five bullets missed. One hit him in the back. That bullet is still inside him.
在他姐姐用锤子砸伤勒罗伊的两周后，在她告诉他不要再来之后，勒罗伊在屋子外面窥视窗户，乔纳森走出去想赶走他，结果勒罗伊开枪射击了他。四五发子弹没打中。一颗子弹打中了他的背部。那颗子弹现在还在他体内。
That shooting is the attempted murder charge that Leroy racked up. And when the police arrested him for it, this is one of the first times that they booked and processed this guy who everybody called Leroy as Lanail Hudson. This is the moment where it seems like he's making the transition from one name to the other. Jonathan said that if I wanted more information about the guy, I should call the pastor at the church near his house-- the one where Leroy lived.
那次枪击案就是勒罗伊背负的谋杀未遂指控。当警察因为这件事逮捕他时，这是他们第一次把这个大家都叫勒罗伊的家伙登记并处理为拉奈尔·哈德森。这似乎是他从一个名字过渡到另一个名字的时刻。乔纳森说如果我想要更多关于那个人的信息，我应该给住在他们房子附近教堂的牧师打电话——那个勒罗伊曾经住过的地方。
Reverend Scott. Elder Scott. He'll be able to give you all the information that you need.
斯科特牧师（Reverend Scott）。斯科特长老（Elder Scott）。他会提供你需要的所有信息。
When I reached Pastor Selwyn Scott and his wife Thomasina, they didn't want to record a conversation for the radio, but they totally remembered Leroy. They said a member of their church found him living on the street when he was 19 or 20. They put him up in the trailer behind the church for maybe a year.
当我联系上塞尔温·斯科特（Selwyn Scott）牧师和他的妻子托马西娜（Thomasina）时，他们不想为广播录制对话，但他们完全记得勒罗伊。他们说，他们教堂的一名成员在他19或20岁时发现他流落街头。他们让他住在教堂后面的拖车里大约一年。
Pastor Scott talked to Leroy a lot, and say that Leroy told him that he was from Guyana. Conveniently for us, Pastor Scott has lived in Trinidad, Barbados, and Guyana, and said that Leroy's accent was definitely from Guyana. And in fact, though most of his arrest records do not list a country of origin or list the United States as the country of origin, one of them, from September 21, 1989, lists his country of origin as Guyana.
斯科特牧师经常和勒罗伊交谈，说勒罗伊告诉他他是来自圭亚那。对我们来说很方便的是，斯科特牧师在特立尼达、巴巴多斯和圭亚那都住过，他说勒罗伊的口音绝对是圭亚那的。事实上，虽然他大多数逮捕记录没有列出原籍国或将美国列为原籍国，但其中一份1989年9月21日的报告中，将他的原籍国列为圭亚那。
Without any prompting, Mrs. Scott brought up the name Lanail Hudson. Actually, she wasn't sure if it was Lionel or Leonard or Lanail, but she said that Leroy found a wallet with the ID in it-- a name like Lanail Hudson-- and she said they told him to mail it back. And after Leroy left the neighborhood, she said that she heard that the young man whose ID it was was dead, and that Leroy had assumed the young man's identity. I let her know that the young man is still very much alive-- no longer perhaps so young-- and I talked to him.
在没有任何暗示的情况下，斯科特太太提到了拉奈尔·哈德森这个名字。实际上，她不确定是莱昂内尔（Lionel）、伦纳德（Leonard）还是拉奈尔（Lanail），但她说勒罗伊捡到一个钱包，里面有身份证——一个像拉奈尔·哈德森的名字——她说他们告诉他把它寄回去。而在勒罗伊离开那个社区后，她说她听说那个身份证的主人死了，勒罗伊冒用了那个年轻人的身份。我让她知道那个年轻人还活着——或许已经不那么年轻了——而且我跟他说过话。
How much money has he cost me?
他让我花了多少钱？
Yeah.
是的。
It wasn't too much. I would say maybe $6,000 or $7,000, he cost me.
没太多。我想大约6000或7000美元吧，他花了我这些钱。
This is Lanail Hudson, the one that I think is the real one. The one who lives in Miami and works for the Department of Corrections. If the price tag on 23 years of identity theft seems shockingly low-- just $6,000, after all-- you should know that that price does not count endless hours on the phone straightening out his credit. He says it took years to convince the IRS that he didn't owe them money. They wanted to garnish his wages for a while.
这就是拉奈尔·哈德森，我认为是真正的那一个。他住在迈阿密，在惩教署工作。如果23年的身份盗窃仅仅是6000美元的代价，看起来惊人地少——毕竟——你应该知道这个价格还不包括他在电话上花费的无数时间来理顺他的信用记录。他说他花了几年时间才说服美国国税局他并不欠他们钱。他们一度想要扣押他的工资。
He says that Leroy, or John Doe, or whatever it is that we're calling him, would buy cars and not make payments, rent cars and not return them, leave hospital bills unpaid. The real Lanail was careful to pay his bills on time and play by the rules. But he couldn't buy a house, because his credit was ruined.
他说，勒罗伊，或者“无名氏”，或者无论我们叫他什么名字，会买车却不还款，租车却不归还，留下未付的医疗账单。真正的拉奈尔一直很小心，按时付账单，按规矩办事。但他买不起房子，因为他的信用记录被毁了。
I believe the most frustrating one-- I believe-- let's see. Let me think. I believe the companies like Sprint and the hospital. These are the companies that are so hard to prove, because they just want their money. And even though they know this person is a criminal, they know this person stole your identity, but I just want the money.
我相信最令人沮丧的一个——我相信——让我们看看。让我想想。我相信是像Sprint和医院这样的公司。这些公司太难证明了，因为他们只想拿回他们的钱。即使他们知道这个人是个罪犯，他们知道这个人偷了你的身份，但我只是想要钱。
I'm like, well, that is not me. I don't have a phone. I'm proving to you that. They don't care about that.
我心想，嗯，那不是我。我没有电话。我正在向你们证明这一点。他们根本不在乎。
On top of all that, he had an attempted murder charge on his name, which was kind of a problem whenever he got pulled over by a cop or applied for a job. Here's what I think we can accurately say about Leroy/John Doe. It seems clear he had some kind of rough childhood, lived on the streets. Went to prison for shooting his girlfriend's brother, and when he got out in the early '90s, he used Lanail Hudson's good name to start a new life.
最重要的是，他的名下还有谋杀未遂的指控，每当他被警察拦截或申请工作时，这都是个麻烦。这就是我认为关于勒罗伊/“无名氏”我们可以准确说出的话：很明显，他经历了一个艰难的童年，生活在街头。因为枪击女朋友的弟弟而入狱，当他在90年代初出狱时，他利用拉奈尔·哈德森的好名字开始了新生活。
Moved to Jacksonville, found a church, met his wife Rosemary there, and told her that he wanted to start over. She says she could see that he'd been broken and thrown away by other people, and fell in love with him. She said he was sweet, quiet, a good dad. They had a house.
搬到了杰克逊维尔，找到了一个教堂，在那里遇到了他的妻子罗斯玛丽，并告诉她他想从头开始。她说她能看出他曾被别人伤害和抛弃，便爱上了他。她说他很贴心、安静，是个好父亲。他们有自己的房子。
Trooper Blanco saw his pay stubs. Said he made good money. As best as we can tell from police records, his violent criminal behavior mostly stops by 1993.
布兰科警官看过他的工资单。说他挣了不少钱。根据警方的记录，我们可以确定他的暴力犯罪行为基本止步于1993年。
That said, it does seem that if he thought he could get away with not paying a bill, he would try. That seems to have continued as he built his new life. Talking to him, I think the way that he sees it is he didn't steal. He didn't run up bills on someone else's credit card. I don't think he ever considered how he might be hurting the Lanail Hudson who lived down in Miami.
话虽如此，如果他认为能逃避付账单，他似乎确实会尝试。这在他建立新生活时似乎一直持续着。和他交谈时，我认为他眼中的自己并没有偷窃。他没有在别人的信用卡上透支。我不认为他曾经考虑过他可能正在伤害迈阿密的那个拉奈尔·哈德森。
I do believe that he wants to get back to his family and kids when he gets out of prison. And so he's stuck as John Doe, because admitting that he's Leroy or somebody else probably does get him deported.
我的确相信他想在出狱后回到他的家人和孩子身边。所以他被困在了“无名氏”的身份里，因为承认自己是勒罗伊或其他什么人很可能会让他被驱逐出境。
Act Two. What are you doing for the test of your life? The woman in this next story is waiting on a piece of paper that-- I think it's not an exaggeration to put it this way-- is going to determine how she will spend the rest of her life. The paper that she's waiting on is a test result-- a genetic test-- for Huntington's disease.
第二幕。你为余生做了什么准备？下一个故事里的女人正在等待一份文件，我认为这样说并不夸张，它将决定她如何度过余生。她等待的文件是一份检测结果——基因检测——针对亨廷顿舞蹈症。
Huntington's disease is a progressive brain disorder. There's a wide range of symptoms, but in the worst cases, people who have it can end up losing physical control of their bodies, sort of like Parkinson's disease. They can also have mental symptoms that are like Alzheimer's or schizophrenia. If you have a parent with Huntington's disease, you have a 50/50 chance of getting it yourself.
亨廷顿舞蹈症是一种进行性脑部疾病。症状范围很广，但在最坏的情况下，患病者可能会失去对身体的物理控制，有点像帕金森病。他们也可能出现类似于阿尔茨海默病或精神分裂症的精神症状。如果你的父母患有亨廷顿舞蹈症，你有50%的机会自己也会患上。
That's the situation in this story. A woman named Kelly-- her mom has Huntington's. Kelly is the youngest of six sisters, and she decided to get tested. She kept an audio diary about what happened.
这就是这个故事的情况。一个叫凯莉（Kelly）的女人——她妈妈患有亨廷顿舞蹈症。凯莉是六个姐妹中最小的一个，她决定进行检测。她记录了一段关于所发生事情的音频日记。
It's 8:30 in the morning. I have an hour and a half until my results, and I'm getting ready. I feel nervous. I'm nervous today. I was a little nervous last night. It started to kick in about midnight, and today, I'm like-- I can't explain it. It's like butterflies.
现在是早上8点30分。离我知道结果还有一个半小时，我正在准备。我感到紧张。我今天很紧张。昨天晚上我也有一点紧张。大约午夜时分这种感觉开始袭来，而今天，我感觉——我无法解释。就像蝴蝶在肚子里飞一样。
Like Kayla said, it's like Christmas, almost, except when you open your present, it's like the [BLEEP] present you ever got. Or it could be the best. So I guess it's kind of like that ugh in your stomach.
就像凯拉（Kayla）说的，就像圣诞节一样，几乎是，只不过当你打开礼物时，那是你收到的最糟糕的礼物。或者也可能是最好的。所以我猜大概就是胃里那种不舒服的感觉。
I'm holding us up. I'm holding us up. I'm cooking breakfast, and we've got to leave.
我在拖延大家。我在拖延大家。我在做早饭，我们得出发了。
I'm 28 years old. I live in Levittown, PA. I live here with my fiancee, Kyle.
我今年28岁。我住在宾夕法尼亚州的莱维敦（Levittown）。我和我的未婚夫凯尔（Kyle）住在这里。
I'm trying to avoid this.
我一直在试图逃避这件事。
My mom has Huntington's disease. Her father had Huntington's disease. I have five sisters. I would say right now, there's at least two of them that show signs. And I've decided to get tested now.
我妈妈患有亨廷顿舞蹈症。她父亲也患有亨廷顿舞蹈症。我有五个姐妹。我会说现在至少有两个表现出了症状。我已经决定现在进行检测。
I am here with my sister, and we're going to ask her a few questions. My oldest sister, Cathy, who is 42 years old, was the one that took care of my mother when she started to get very sick. She's showing symptoms of the disease. How are you feeling now?
我和我的姐姐在这里，我们要问她几个问题。我42岁的大姐凯茜（Cathy），是在我母亲刚开始病重时照顾她的人。她表现出了这种疾病的症状。你现在感觉怎么样？
Good.
很好。
How did you feel before? We'll say a month ago.
你之前感觉如何？我们假设一个月前。
A month ago? Horrible. It feels like your mind is going. It's just, you try to think, and your body doesn't allow it to think. It's like, you can't remember.
一个月前？糟糕透了。感觉就像你的思想在消退。就是，你试图思考，但你的身体不允许你思考。就像，你记不住。
And you look at something, and you're like, OK, I know how to do this. Like, I know it, I know it, I know it, I know it. And you can't do it. Your brain is just not working. And you feel like you're dying, as someone would describe it.
你看着某样东西，心里想，好吧，我知道怎么做。就像，我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道。但你做不到。你的大脑就是不工作了。就像有人描述的那样，感觉你快要死了。
Like you're panicking, almost?
就像你快要恐慌了一样？
Yeah, yeah. And then it's kind of like, you wake up confused and try to-- you know you have to go to the bathroom, but you can't make it fast enough.
是的，是的。然后就像是，你醒来时感到困惑，试图——你知道你必须去洗手间，但你没法足够快地赶过去。
So then you would pee yourself when that happened?
所以当那种情况发生时，你会尿在身上？
That happened. Yeah. That happened recently.
那是发生过的。是的。那是最近发生的。
My biggest fear is like, what if your mind is trapped inside this body that can't move?
我最大的恐惧是，如果你的思想被困在这个无法移动的身体里怎么办？
That's why I kept telling everybody. I was doing the one word thing, and it was kind of--
所以我一直告诉大家。我一直在练习只说一个词，而且那种感觉……
What was your one word? Because Mommy's was funny, funny, funny.
你的那个词是什么？因为妈妈的是“有趣，有趣，有趣”。
Funny, yeah. Mine was don't know what to do. Like, don't know, don't know, I don't know. That's-- don't know. Don't know.
有趣，是的。我的是“不知道该怎么办”。就像，不知道，不知道，我不知道。就是——不知道。不知道。
That's why I can't go see Mommy. Remember? I just can't go, because I just get--
这就是为什么我不能去看妈妈。记得吗？我就是不能去，因为我只会感到——
Psychologically messed up.
心理崩溃。
Yeah. It just kills me.
是的。这真的要了我的命。
I mean, from what I hear, my mom was actually getting sick when she was pregnant with me. So she was pretty much sick from when I was born. I think I was 15 when she went to the nursing home. So it's been a while.
我的意思是，据我所知，我妈妈怀我的时候其实就开始生病了。所以她从我出生起基本上就病着。我想我15岁时她就进了疗养院。所以已经有一段时间了。
And she's-- I can't even explain it. It's like, she's very atrophied. Her arms are stuck up. Her legs are basically stuck. Like, she doesn't move at all. She does nothing.
而且她——我甚至无法解释。就像，她萎缩得很严重。她的手臂僵住了。她的腿基本上不动了。就像，她完全不动。她什么也不做。
Like, the best thing you could say is just a shell sitting there. No kid should ever have to see the [BLEEP] that went down in my house when we were kids. Like, crazy stuff.
最好的说法就是坐在那里的一个躯壳。没有孩子应该看到我们在小时候家里发生的那种烂事。就像，疯狂的事情。
I came home one day and everything was in plastic bags. Everything was contaminated, and disgusting, and she was allergic to everything. I'd come home and be like, what the hell? She's nuts again.
有一天我回家，所有东西都在塑料袋里。一切都被污染了，恶心透了，而且她对什么都过敏。我回到家心想，搞什么鬼？她又疯了。
My friends would come over and say to me, like, your mom's nuts. What's going on? Yeah, I know.
我的朋友们过来对我说，你妈疯了。怎么回事？是啊，我知道。
And I was embarrassed. I was actually mad at her. I had terrible feelings towards her. Even when she went to assisted living, she'd call like 80 times a day.
我很尴尬。我其实很生她的气。我对她有糟糕的感觉。甚至当她进了辅助生活中心，她一天打80次电话。
Stop calling! And I'd hang up on her. And I was so mean to her. But I didn't have that understanding of what it was at all.
别再打了！我会挂断她的电话。我对她太刻薄了。但我根本不了解那是什么情况。
So now another question I want to ask. Why haven't you ever gotten tested? Why didn't you think, even now-- what was your biggest fear? The insurance aspect of it?
那么现在我想问另一个问题。你为什么从来没有做过检测？你为什么没想过，即使是现在——你最大的恐惧是什么？保险方面的问题吗？
Insurance. The denial of wasting my life.
保险。否认我浪费了我的人生。
Like, you feel like you didn't do what you should have done.
就像，你觉得你没做你应该做的事。
Yeah. Like I should have lived more.
是的。就像我本应该活得更精彩一点。
Lived. Yeah. For me, it's I don't know if I'll be liberated if they tell me I have it, because like you said, you think about it every day. And if you know you have it, like you said, I'm going to live balls to the wall. I'm going to do everything. I'm going to make a list and do everything I want to do.
活得精彩。是啊。对我来说，我不知道如果他们告诉我我有这种病，我是不是会解脱，因为就像你说的，你每天都在想它。如果你知道你有，就像你说的，我会活得肆无忌惮。我会做每一件事。我会列个清单，去做我所有想做的事。
Uh-huh. None of us should be having kids.
嗯哼。我们谁都不应该要孩子。
For me it's moreso the care of the child. Now, I don't want my kid to go through what I went through. I had you to raise me, thank God, but with Mommy, I saw the most terrible part of someone that was supposed to be my mother.
对我来说，更多的是照顾孩子的问题。现在，我不希望我的孩子经历我所经历的。我有你抚养我，感谢上帝，但对于妈妈，我看到了那个本应该是我母亲的人最可怕的一面。
That's why I didn't want Kayla taking care of me, because I did it with Mommy.
这就是为什么我不希望凯拉（Kayla）照顾我，因为我和妈妈经历过这一切。
Yeah, it's so hard. Like, with Kayla-- so if Kayla has it, what would you feel? Like, [BLEEP].
是啊，太难了。就像，凯拉——如果凯拉有了，你会感觉如何？比如，该死。
Yeah, I'd feel guilty.
是的，我会感到内疚。
I don't feel like you have it, Kel.
我不觉得你有，凯。
I hope not.
希望没有。
I don't. I don't think you do.
我不觉得。我不觉得你有。
My niece Kayla's here with me today, because she's going to come with me to come get my results.
我侄女凯拉今天和我在一起，因为她要陪我来拿检测结果。
I hope I'm right.
希望我是对的。
It's a flattering thought.
这是一个令人受宠若惊的想法。
My name is Kayla. I'm 21 years old. My mom is Cathy. I recently got tested for Huntington's, and I was told that I definitely have the gene, just not displaying signs yet. Like, physical signs.
我叫凯拉。我21岁。我妈妈是凯茜。我最近做了亨廷顿舞蹈症检测，他们告诉我我确实携带了基因，只是还没显示出迹象。比如，身体迹象。
I decided not to tell my mom, because I don't want her to feel guilty for me having it. She's already depressed and on edge, and I wouldn't want to push her over. I literally don't have any family support besides Kelly. Like, Mom or Dad's side. Kelly is the only person I have who understands it that is behind me on it.
我决定不告诉我妈，因为我不想让她因为我有这种病而感到内疚。她已经很抑郁并且处于崩溃边缘了，我不想把她推下去。我除了凯莉以外真的没有任何家庭支持。比如妈妈或爸爸那边。凯莉是我唯一了解这种情况、支持我的人。
I haven't told anybody, really, in my family besides Kelly. We've talked about it our whole lives, and I don't want her to have it. But it's like, one part of me that if Kelly has it, I'm not alone. So I have really mixed feelings on it.
除了凯莉，我真的没告诉家里任何人。我们一辈子都在谈论它，我不希望她有。但感觉就像，我内心的一部分希望如果凯莉有的话，我就不会孤单了。所以我的感受非常复杂。
OK, we're in the backyard just hanging out. Kayla's on her fifth cigarette. Clearly she's more nervous than me.
好的，我们正待在后院。凯拉在抽第五支烟。显然她比我紧张多了。
Actually, since I found out my results, I feel like I smoke more. I really do, because now I'm like, screw it. Before, people were always like, oh, it's so unhealthy. You'll get cancer. And what more can happen, you know what I mean?
其实，自从我知道结果后，我感觉我抽得更多了。真的，因为现在我就想，去他的。以前，人们总是说，哦，这太不健康了。你会得癌症。还能发生什么更糟的事，你懂我的意思吗？
The first thing I wanted to do after I got my test results was I wanted to order food and watch stand-up. And that's what I did the whole night. Ate pizza. But I just treated it as another night, you know?
拿到检测结果后，我做的第一件事就是点外卖，看单口喜剧。我整晚都这么做了。吃了披萨。但我只是把它当作普通的一晚，你懂吗？
I booked the day, because I knew that I wouldn't be sitting around. And I have a wedding shower Saturday at church, because now we have to start going to the church for the wedding. And then dinner plans with his mom, so I kind of booked the entire weekend to make sure that I don't have a second by myself to cry.
我预定了这一天，因为我知道我不会坐着干等。周六我在教堂有个婚礼派对，因为现在我们得开始去教堂筹备婚礼了。然后还得陪他妈妈吃晚饭，所以我基本上安排满了整个周末，确保我自己不会有一秒钟单独待着哭泣。
All right, here we go. We're getting in the car and getting ready to leave. Do you want me to brush your hair? That's another thing. If I do get sick, just make sure you do my hair. Like, brush my hair and don't cut it short.
好了，我们要开始了。我们要上车准备出发了。你想让我帮你梳头吗？那是另一回事。如果我病了，确保你帮我弄头发。比如，帮我梳头发，别把它剪短。
I don't want short hair like my mom. They did that to my mom. I hate short hair.
我不想要像我妈那样短的头发。他们对我妈做了那个。我讨厌短发。
You don't have to do the makeup thing. Unless you want to. Like, when you take me out to dinner.
你不需要帮我化妆。除非你想。比如，当你带我出去吃晚饭时。
See, I'm cool. Just stick me in a nursing home. I'll be fine.
你看，我没问题。就把我塞进疗养院吧。我会没事的。
We'll put you in one of those nice homes down there.
我们会把你安顿在那边其中一家不错的疗养院里。
Yeah.
是啊。
We'll settle you in nicely. We'll make--
我们会把你照顾得很好的。我们会——
I'll make friends. I'll make friends. My mom made friends. She loved the assisted living place. Remember she had a boyfriend there?
我会交朋友的。我会交朋友的。我妈就交了朋友。她很喜欢那个辅助生活中心。记得吗，她在那里有个男朋友？
Yeah. That's what I'm saying. I get to just chill out and play checkers all day. Sounds good.
记得。我就是说这个。我可以去那里清闲地玩玩跳棋。听起来不错。
Probably you're gonna be a little shaky. Nobody's gonna want to play with you.
到时候你可能会有点手抖。没人想和你一起玩了。
Probably shouldn't play Jenga. [LAUGHING] That's terrible.
那可能不应该玩积木叠叠乐了。[大笑] 那太糟糕了。
All right. I've got to go in there. What time is it? Wait. [BLEEP] It's getting real now.
好了。我得进去了。现在几点了？等等。该死。现在来真的了。
OK, it's 10:30, and we're about to go into Shayna's office for my results.
好了，现在是10点30分，我们要进去找谢娜（Shayna）医生拿结果了。
Have you been nervous, or pretty chill, or--
你是感到紧张，还是比较放松，或者——
Yeah. I feel like I might throw up.
是啊。我觉得我可能会吐。
You do? OK. Do you want me to just cut right to the chase?
你真的吗？好的。你想让我直接切入重点吗？
I don't know about that.
我不知道。
OK. Well, I'm happy to do that. Unless you guys wanted to talk a little bit--
好的。没问题，我很乐意这样做。除非你们想先聊聊——
No, I want to get to it.
不，我想直接知道结果。
No, we just want to know.
不，我们只是想知道。
You just want to know. OK, I was going to say, some people want to have a conversation about what would happen. OK, great. Your results were normal. You're not going to have Huntington's disease. So it's not what you were expecting, I know.
你们只是想知道。好吧，我本来想说，有些人想先聊聊如果结果出来了会发生什么。好吧，太棒了。结果正常。你不会患亨廷顿舞蹈症。所以我知道这和你预想的不一样。
See, I told you.
看吧，我告诉过你。
[CRYING] Oh my god. [CRYING] Oh my god. I'm sorry.
[哭泣] 哦天哪。[哭泣] 哦天哪。对不起。
It's OK.
没关系。
I can't even believe this. Like, are you sure?
我甚至无法相信。比如，你确定吗？
I'll show you the paper. I can show you the words. But yes, you inherited both normal alleles. Right there, the negatives. So negative is normal.
我可以给你看那张纸。我可以给你看文字。但是的，你遗传了两个正常的等位基因。就在那儿，阴性结果。阴性就是正常。
[CRYING] Can we have that?
[哭泣] 我们能留着它吗？
Absolutely. I do need to make photocopies, but you can absolutely have it.
当然。我需要复印一份，但你们绝对可以留着。
[SNIFFLE] You mind if I just step outside?
[抽泣] 你介意我出去一下吗？
No, go ahead. That's fine.
不，去吧。没问题。
If you go to the right a little bit, you can have some privacy in that space.
如果你稍微往右边走一点，在那边你可以有私人空间。
I'm just going to go to the lobby.
我只是去大厅坐坐。
OK.
好的。
It's hard. It's hard for her.
真难。对她来说真难。
Yeah. And a lot of people think that just normal is easy, and everything's good, but it's complicated, you know? It's really complicated.
是啊。很多人认为结果正常就很轻松，一切都好，但情况很复杂，你知道吗？真的很复杂。
The good thing is, at least I'll be able to take care of her.
好的一面是，至少我能照顾她。
Yeah.
是啊。
That's the good part of it.
那是件好事。
Yeah.
是啊。
But I don't want her to be alone. It probably wasn't a good idea for her to be here, now that I think about it. Like, I wanted her for her support, but then it seems like she's probably going to be upset about it.
但我不想让她一个人待着。现在想来，让她过来可能不是个好主意。比如，我需要她的支持，但现在看来她可能会为此很难过。
Yeah.
是啊。
It says, result negative. This patient is predicted to be unaffected by Huntington's disease caused by the expansion of the CAG repeat in the HD gene. Laboratory results and submitted clinical information reviewed by Franklin Quan, Ph.D.
上面写着，结果阴性。根据对亨廷顿基因中CAG重复序列扩展引起的原因，预测该患者不会受到亨廷顿舞蹈症的影响。实验室结果和提交的临床信息由富兰克林·权（Franklin Quan）博士审查。
Like, you have to keep looking at it to make sure that they didn't screw up somewhere. Like, are you sure? Are you sure?
就像，你得一直盯着看，确保他们没有在什么地方搞砸。比如，你确定吗？你确定吗？
Kelly's audio diary was produced by Paige Cowett of WNYC. Coming up, how your life can change because of something that happens with your parents in the parking lot of a Kohl's department store. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
凯莉的音频日记由WNYC的佩奇·考维特（Paige Cowett）制作。接下来，当你的父母在科尔（Kohl's）百货公司的停车场发生某事时，你的生活会如何改变。那是下一分钟的内容。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's theme, It Says So Right Here. Stories where what is written on paper in black and white has enormous power over somebody's life. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three-- There's A Signed Line Between Love and Hate. Ben Calhoun has this story of politics and one very particular piece of paperwork.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题。今天的主题是《白纸黑字》。讲述那些纸上白纸黑字的内容对某人生活产生巨大影响的故事。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕——爱与恨之间有一道签名的界线。本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）带来了这个关于政治和一张非常特殊的文件故事。
If you took a wholesome storybook version of the state of Wisconsin and you turned it into a person, you might get a college student named Josh Inglett. Josh grew up in Portage, this small city near the middle of the state. His dad, a Lutheran minister. His mom, a substitute kindergarten teacher.
如果你把威斯康星州的故事书式版本变成一个人，你可能会得到一个叫乔什·英格莱特（Josh Inglett）的大学生。乔什在波蒂奇（Portage）长大，这是该州中部的一个小城市。他的父亲是一名路德宗牧师。他的母亲是一名幼儿园代课老师。
Josh got good grades in high school, where he played quarterback for his school's mostly losing football team. For college, he only looked at Wisconsin state schools. And listen to how he's paying for it.
乔什高中成绩很好，他在学校那支总是输球的足球队担任四分卫。对于大学，他只看威斯康星州的公立学校。听听他是怎么付学费的。
Well, originally, my parents helped me out a little bit, but I kind of rejected the idea. I noticed some of my friends whose parents were paying for school or were assisting them in school didn't really take ownership, I guess, of their education, and they did some extracurricular activities that were not as fruitful, I guess, towards their education, and wouldn't help them, along the way, get the full learning experience at school.
嗯，最初，我父母帮了我一点，但我拒绝了这个想法。我注意到我的一些朋友，他们的父母为他们支付学费或在学校资助他们，他们并没有真正对自己的教育负责，我想，而且他们做了一些课外活动，对我来说不够充实，而且不会帮助他们在此过程中获得完整的学习体验。
OK, I just want to note how he's so politely trying not to slag his friends for partying instead of studying, and that he's being so earnest and trying to live by principles. This is what it's like to talk to Josh.
好的，我只想指出他是如何礼貌地试图不责骂他的朋友们只顾派对而不学习，以及他是多么诚恳，试图按照原则生活。和乔什谈话就是这种感觉。
I've actually turned away-- last year, I didn't even accept any financial aid. I decided I wanted to try paying for everything and graduate from college debt-free and relatively unassisted from my parents.
我实际上拒绝了——去年，我甚至没有接受任何经济援助。我决定我想尝试支付一切费用，大学毕业时零债务，而且相对不依赖我父母的帮助。
Our story with Josh actually starts right here, once Josh is at college. He ended up going to the University of Wisconsin at Platteville, and his sophomore year, to pay his tuition bills, he became an RA. And because of that, he ended up going to the statewide convention for RAs throughout the whole UW system. And this is key, because this RA conference kind of blew Josh's mind a little.
我们和乔什的故事其实就在这里开始，一旦乔什上了大学。他最终进入了威斯康星大学普拉特维尔分校（University of Wisconsin at Platteville），在大二时，为了支付学费，他当了一名宿管（RA）。正因为如此，他最终去了整个威大系统RA的全州大会。这是关键，因为这次RA会议有点让乔什大开眼界。
When he was there, he started hearing about students at other UW schools who were helping to make their schools better. They were getting money and starting programs. And Josh was just like, I want to do that for my school. Almost on cue, he hears about a student position with the Board of Regents for the University of Wisconsin system.
当他在那里时，他开始听说其他分校的学生正在帮助改善他们的学校。他们正在获得资金并启动项目。乔什当时就想，我也想为我的学校做同样的事情。就在这时，他听说了一个威斯康星大学系统董事会的学生职位。
Now, the Board of Regents might sound like some obscure, meaningless hunk of bureaucracy, but it's actually the governing board for Wisconsin's entire $5 billion a year university system. It's got two seats for students. So Josh applies.
现在，董事会听起来可能是一个晦涩、毫无意义的官僚机构，但它实际上是威斯康星州每年50亿美元大学系统的管理委员会。它有两个学生席位。所以乔什申请了。
Soon, he gets a call from the governor's office. That's what a big deal the Board of Regents is. The governor actually appoints the student regents.
很快，他接到了州长办公室的电话。这就是董事会的重要性。州长实际上任命了学生董事。
So Josh goes to the state capital, Madison, to interview with Governor Scott Walker's staff. He's a little nervous at first, but he hits it off with the guy who's running the selection process. Josh is telling him about playing quarterback in Portage, and as it turns out, the guy running the interview actually grew up in a nearby town called Waunakee.
所以乔什去了州首府麦迪逊，面试州长斯科特·沃克（Scott Walker）的团队。他起初有点紧张，但他和负责选拔过程的人一见如故。乔什告诉他关于在波蒂奇打四分卫的事，结果发现负责面试的那个人实际上是在附近一个叫瓦纳基（Waunakee）的城镇长大的。
We had shared a joke, actually, that he went to Waunakee High School, which is a big time rival of Portage in sports and things. And they always beat us, too, so that was a good laugh. I felt like it was probably the best interview that I had ever had.
我们实际上开了一个玩笑，他说他去了瓦纳基高中，那是波蒂奇在体育等方面的宿敌。而且他们总是打败我们，所以那是一个很好的笑话。我觉得那可能是我经历过的最好的面试。
Josh goes through weeks of interviewing and vetting, and then it happens. Governor Walker's office puts out a press release announcing Josh's nomination. This is what Governor Walker says about Josh in it. "I am pleased to appoint Joshua, and I know he will serve the UW system and his fellow students well."
乔什经历了数周的面试和审查，然后事情发生了。沃克州长的办公室发布了一份新闻稿，宣布了乔什的提名。沃克州长在里面这样评价乔什：“我很高兴任命约书亚，我知道他会很好地服务于威大系统和他的同学们。”
A couple days later, Walker's staff calls Josh back to Madison for this big day of official stuff. They coach him and introduce him to lawmakers, who have to approve his nomination. There's meeting and greeting. There's a big long day of that. And then Josh goes home.
几天后，沃克的工作人员叫乔什回麦迪逊参加这一天的官方事务。他们指导他并把他介绍给立法者，他们必须批准他的提名。有会议和问候。经历了漫长的一天。然后乔什回家了。
I got a call 5:30, so it must have been about an hour, probably, once I got back. I got a call from the governor's office-- the adviser on education to the governor. He told me that I had done a good job. That's kind of how he started the conversation, and then continued to ask me if I had signed the recall petition.
我在5点半接到电话，所以肯定大概过了一个小时，我回到家后。我接到了州长办公室的电话——州长的教育顾问。他告诉我我做得很棒。他就是这样开始对话的，然后继续问我是否签署了罢免请愿书。
The recall petition. Maybe you remember this whole political bloodbath Wisconsin went through a little while ago. Maybe you don't. But quick synopsis.
罢免请愿书。也许你还记得威斯康星州前阵子经历的那场政治大屠杀。也许你不记得了。但我简单概括一下。
Scott Walker, conservative Republican, gets elected in 2010. And almost immediately, he announces a ton of really controversial things-- dramatic budget cuts or, more inflammatory, eliminating collective bargaining rights for most public sector employees-- nurses, teachers, et cetera, et cetera. The state goes bananas.
2010年，共和党保守派斯科特·沃克当选。几乎立即，他宣布了一系列非常有争议的事情——戏剧性的预算削减，或者更具煽动性的，取消大多数公共部门雇员——护士、教师等人的集体谈判权。全州陷入疯狂。
A year later, people organize an attempt to recall Walker and kick him out of office. And they collect about a million signatures for that. More than a quarter of all the registered voters in the state signed to have Walker recalled.
一年后，人们组织了一次罢免沃克并把他踢下台的尝试。他们收集了大约一百万个签名。全州超过四分之一的注册选民签署了罢免沃克的要求。
And so they do it. They have a vote, and the organizers fail. Walker wins. Stays in office.
于是他们付诸行动。他们进行了投票，但组织者失败了。沃克赢了。留任了。
OK, all of that happened before all this. The recall petition happened when Josh Inglett was barely out of high school. And yet, that's what this person from the governor's office was asking Josh about on the phone. Had he signed a petition to have Walker recalled?
好的，所有这些都发生在那之前。罢免请愿书发生时，乔什·英格莱特刚高中毕业。然而，这就是州长办公室的那个人在电话里问乔什的事。他是否签署了罢免沃克的请愿书？
And I asked him why, I guess. And he said, I just need to know. And I didn't even remember, I guess, at that point. It was something, I guess, that I had kind of forgotten about-- something that was not a big point in my life. Not something that I marked on my calendar by any sense of the imagination.
我问他为什么，我想。他说，我只需要知道。我当时甚至记不起来了，我想。这对我来说已经是一个被遗忘的事情——一件不是我生活重点的事情。并不是我凭想象在日历上标记的任何日子。
Had it been something that Josh marked on his calendar, the date on the entry would have been December 26, 2011. Josh was home from college for the holidays, and he was out with his family after Christmas sale shopping. Josh says he remembers they were in the parking lot of a Kohl's department store, and there was this guy collecting signatures.
如果那真是乔什在日历上标记的事情，那么那天的条目日期将是2011年12月26日。乔什因假期从大学回家，他和家人出去参加圣诞节后的促销购物。乔什说他记得当时他们在一家科尔百货公司的停车场，有人在收集签名。
And Josh says while he was at home, he'd been hearing what Walker's collective bargaining legislation and budget cutting-- what this was going to do in his hometown of Portage. His parents were talking about it, and so were his old teachers.
乔什说，当他在家时，他一直在听说沃克的集体谈判立法和预算削减——这在他家乡波蒂奇会产生什么影响。他的父母在谈论它，他的老老师们也在谈论。
We were preparing ourselves, I guess, for teachers in my district to be fired and to lose their jobs. There was going to be a downsize, I guess, of 20 or 30 teachers who were going to get fired or dismissed because of Governor Walker's policy against the unions.
我们当时正在准备，我想，准备迎接我们学区的老师被解雇和失去工作。那将是一次裁员，我想，会有20或30名老师因为沃克州长反对工会的政策而被解雇或辞退。
All of this was bad news for Josh's mom. Again, she was a substitute teacher. Mostly taught kindergarten.
所有这些对乔什的妈妈来说都是坏消息。再一次，她是一名代课老师。主要是教幼儿园。
And around this time, with Josh off at college, she was looking for a full-time teaching job. She hadn't been able to find one, though, and with Walker's budget cuts and union legislation, Josh knew her chances would only get worse. So he's there in the parking lot, standing there with his mom, and there's the guy with the clipboard who's like, sign here, kid.
而在那个时候，随着乔什在大学读书，她一直在找一份全职教学工作。但她一直没能找到，随着沃克的预算削减和工会立法，乔什知道她找到工作的机会只会变得更糟。所以他当时在停车场，和妈妈站在一起，那个拿着剪贴板的人就像是，在这里签字，孩子。
And so I signed it.
于是我签了。
It sounds like it was mostly out of support for your mom, actually.
听起来这主要是为了支持你妈妈，其实。
Oh, very much so, yeah. I knew that she wouldn't be able to get a full-time position if Governor Walker's policies came to fruition. It seemed like a violent situation for the people who were my role models-- my parents, my teachers, my coaches. They all were being affected by it, and it was something that I didn't really even think about. It just seemed like that was what I should do. That's the best thing for the people who I love in my life.
哦，非常支持，是的。我知道如果沃克州长的政策实施，她就不可能获得全职职位。对于那些作为我榜样的人——我的父母、我的老师、我的教练，这看起来就像是一种暴力的情况。他们都受到了影响，这是我甚至没有考虑的事情。这看起来只是我应该做的事情。这对我在生活中爱的人来说是最好的事情。
OK, so back to this phone call from the governor's office. Walker's staff had spent a couple months interviewing and vetting Josh. It had just been hours since they were parading him through the capital. Now they were asking him if he'd ever signed the recall.
好的，回到州长办公室的那个电话。沃克的工作人员花了几个月时间面试和审查乔什。他们把他介绍到首府才过了几个小时。现在他们正在问他是否曾经签署过罢免令。
And again, at first, he couldn't even remember. Josh actually had to get off the phone with the staffer and call his dad to ask him if he had, in fact, signed the petition.
再一次，起初，他甚至想不起来。乔什实际上不得不放下电话，联系工作人员，然后给爸爸打电话，问他是否真的签了请愿书。
It was something that I guess I had to think about, and I think that may have turned him off, and that he was kind of upset about that. But I ultimately told him that I had signed it, and he said, thank you. And I asked him, is there a problem?
那是我猜我不得不考虑的事情，我想这可能让他很不爽，而且他对此有点生气。但我最终告诉他我签了，他说，谢谢。我问他，有什么问题吗？
And he said, no, it's just something that my boss needs to know. And so I said, OK. And he said, all right, we'll call you later.
他说，不，这只是我老板需要知道的事情。所以我说，好的。他说，好吧，我们稍后再给你打电话。
Josh was stressed out by all this. And so that night, he wakes up. Middle of the night. 4:30 in the morning.
乔什被这一切弄得压力很大。所以那天晚上，他醒了。半夜。凌晨4点30分。
He has a voice mail from Walker's chief of staff, saying, whenever you get this, call me right away. It's possible the chief of staff did not mean, even if it's 4:30 in the morning, go ahead and give me a ring. But Josh gives the man what he's asking for.
他收到了沃克办公厅主任的语音邮件，说，无论你什么时候看到这个，马上回电给我。可能办公厅主任并不是说，即使是凌晨4点30分，也要给我打个电话。但乔什给了那人他所要求的。
And 4:30 in the morning on that Thursday, they told me that I was being rescinded.
在那个周四的凌晨4点30分，他们告诉我我的提名被取消了。
Rescinded. They were withdrawing Josh's nomination.
取消了。他们收回了乔什的提名。
And the tone of the conversation was very somber. Not welcoming. And that was by the chief of staffer, the gentleman who was very powerful in the governor's office. I really felt lost. I guess I felt a sense of betrayal, because I viewed these people as people I looked up to.
谈话的语调非常沉重。不欢迎。那是办公厅主任打来的，那位在州长办公室非常有权势的绅士。我真的感到迷茫。我猜我感到了一种背叛感，因为我视这些人为你仰望的人。
Josh says the governor's staff didn't ask about his reasoning-- why he'd signed. He didn't get to explain that despite his signature, Josh was, politically speaking, actually on their side. He's a Republican.
乔什说州长的工作人员没有问他的理由——为什么要签。他没有机会解释，尽管他签了名，但在政治上，乔什实际上是在他们这一边的。他是共和党人。
Josh had grown up listening to debates between his Republican grandparents and his Democratic parents. But when he signed the petition, he says, he wasn't political at all. Remember, Josh was only 18. He didn't even care enough to vote in the recall election. Then, after he signed, Josh did what a lot of people do in college.
乔什从小就是听着共和党祖父母和民主党父母之间的辩论长大的。但当他签署请愿书时，他说，他根本没有政治倾向。记住，乔什当时才18岁。他甚至懒得在罢免选举中投票。然后，在签署之后，乔什做了很多大学生做的事情。
That's really when I came into my own, and that's where I developed my own beliefs and my own political thoughts. And I like a smaller central government, and we need to balance the budget. Those are issues I see facing my generation, and that's something that I'm really passionate about.
那才是我真正独立的时候，也是我发展出自己的信仰和政治思想的时候。我喜欢更小的中央政府，我们需要平衡预算。这些是我看到我这一代人面临的问题，这确实是我非常热衷的事情。
And Josh doesn't just support Republican policies. Specifically, he supports Governor Walker.
乔什不仅支持共和党的政策。具体来说，他支持沃克州长。
Oh, very much so. I'm a great advocate for entitlement reform, and the policies that he's putting in place there, and what he's doing for our workforce and things. I have great admiration for the man.
哦，非常支持。我是福利改革的伟大倡导者，以及他正在实施的政策，还有他为我们的劳动力所做的一切。我对这个人怀有崇高的敬意。
And yet, Walker's staff thought Josh was the enemy because his signature was sitting there on that petition, and there would be no convincing them otherwise.
然而，沃克的工作人员认为乔什是敌人，因为他的签名就在那份请愿书上，并且无法说服他们。
As for how Josh's signature even came up in the first place, the story had been broken by a couple conservative websites the same day Josh was at the capital for all the official stuff. Those websites found out because when Wisconsin politics had gone all nuts and the recall happened, a few conservative and Tea Party groups decided to put the recall signatures online. Several of them went through the petitions, activists and volunteers painstakingly data entering nearly a million signatures.
至于乔什的签名是如何出现的，这个故事在乔什在首府参加官方活动的那天就被几个保守派网站捅了出来。那些网站发现是因为当威斯康星州的政治陷入混乱且发生罢免时，一些保守派和茶党团体决定将罢免签名发布在网上。其中几个通过了请愿书，活动家和志愿者费尽心机地录入了近一百万个签名。
So a couple conservative blogs found Josh's signature and posted stories and called the governor for comment. Publicly, the governor's office didn't say why it was taking Josh's nomination back, only said they were withdrawing his name and choosing someone else. But once the news came out and people read about the signature, they connected the dots with a very straight line of common sense. And just like that, the governor's office turned a non-story-- a story of an appointment that nobody would usually hear about to a government board that a lot of people don't know exists-- they turned that into a juicy news story, one of political revenge and partisan warfare.
所以几个保守派博客找到了乔什的签名并发表了故事，还打电话给州长征求意见。公开场合，州长办公室没有说为什么要收回乔什的提名，只是说他们正在撤回他的名字并选择其他人。但一旦新闻出来，人们读到了签名，他们就用非常直观的常识连点成线。就这样，州长办公室把一个非故事——一个没人通常会听说的政府董事会的任命，一个很多人不知道存在的董事会——变成了 Juicy 的新闻，一个关于政治复仇和党派战争的故事。
I think I heard it on the radio in the morning is how I think I got the news. I was stunned.
我想我早上是在广播里听到这个新闻的。我惊呆了。
This is Wisconsin State Senator Dale Schultz. And to be clear, like Governor Walker, Dale Schultz is a Republican. He's not some Democrat looking to embarrass Walker. He's been serving as a Republican in the Wisconsin state legislature since Governor Walker was a freshman in high school.
这是威斯康星州参议员戴尔·舒尔茨（Dale Schultz）。明确一下，像沃克州长一样，戴尔·舒尔茨也是共和党人。他不是为了让沃克难堪的民主党人。他自沃克州长高中一年级起就在威斯康星州立法机构担任共和党参议员。
When the governor's office had broken the bad news to Josh, they told him they had to do this, because with the recall signature, Josh would never make it through the Republican-controlled state Senate. Senator Schultz is on the committee that was in charge of Josh's appointment.
当州长办公室向乔什传达坏消息时，他们告诉他他们必须这样做，因为有了罢免签名，乔什永远无法通过共和党控制的州参议院。舒尔茨参议员在负责乔什任命的委员会里。
So when they said that they didn't want to drag him through the process of going through the legislature, how confident are you that if the governor had pushed him, that he would have made it through?
所以当他们说他们不想让他经历立法机构的程序时，如果州长推动他，你有多大的信心他能通过？
100%. I've been in the state Senate over 20 years, and the Wisconsin legislature passes on all gubernatorial appointments. Rarely do we say no to anyone. And this young man was very impressive.
100%。我在州参议院待了20多年了，威斯康星州立法机构会对所有州长任命进行表决。我们很少对任何人说不。而这个年轻人非常令人印象深刻。
Schultz says he likes the governor. Voted for him. Supports him. But the Josh Inglett thing-- he says he didn't like it.
舒尔茨说他喜欢州长。投了他的票。支持他。但乔什·英格莱特的这件事——他说他不喜欢。
The only time I've ever seen or heard of a list like this being used before was Hugo Chavez in Venezuela, when they tried to recall him down there. It seems to me I remember reading an Economist article on that subject that it became a list of enemies, so to speak. And I was just shocked.
我以前只在委内瑞拉的查韦斯身上见过或听说过这样的名单，当他们试图在下面罢免他时。我记得我读过《经济学人》关于那个主题的一篇文章，它变成了所谓的敌人名单。我当时感到震惊。
Hearing the news, Senator Schultz fired off a letter to the governor that very same day, actually, which I have a copy of it here. "Dear Governor Walker, I write to respectfully ask that you reconsider rescinding the nomination of UW Platteville student Joshua Inglett to the UW Board of Regents. I'm not sure about you, but as for me, I know in my youth, and particularly during college, that I experimented and made decisions that, upon further thought and growth, I wouldn't make again. I'm thankful others gave me opportunities to learn and grow as a person and professionally."
听到这个消息后，舒尔茨参议员在那天就发了一封信给州长，实际上我这里有一份复印件。“亲爱的沃克州长，我写信是为了礼貌地请求您重新考虑撤回威大普拉特维尔分校学生乔什·英格莱特加入威大董事会的提名。我不确定您的情况如何，但就我而言，我知道在我的青年时期，特别是在大学期间，我进行了尝试并做出了一些决定，经过进一步的思考和成长，我不会再做出那样的决定。我很感谢其他人给了我学习和成长为个人以及在职业上成长的机会。”
In the following paragraphs here, Schultz points out that after Scott Walker won the recall election, he said he regretted all the ugliness, and he called for bipartisanship and healing and peace. And then Schultz's letter continues.
在接下来的段落里，舒尔茨指出，在斯科特·沃克赢得罢免选举后，他说他后悔所有的丑陋，并呼吁两党合作、治愈与和平。然后舒尔茨的信继续写道。
"I agree with you that for our state to heal, we must look past those issues which divided us and focus on those passions we share and move our great state forward. I can think of no greater way to put these feelings into action than by reconsidering Mr. Inglett's appointment."
“我同意您的看法，为了我们的州能够治愈，我们必须超越那些分裂我们的问题，关注我们共同的热情，推动我们伟大的州前进。我想不出比重新考虑英格莱特先生的任命更好的将这些情感付诸行动的方式了。”
I've called Governor Walker's office repeatedly. After weeks of calls, I have yet to hear anything. They haven't even declined to comment. The only statements from the governor about Josh Inglett that I've been able to find are in newspapers and in a few TV stories, and they all seem to have come from this one question and answer session Walker did right when all this happened.
我多次致电沃克州长的办公室。经过几周的电话，我还没听到任何回应。他们甚至没有拒绝评论。关于乔什·英格莱特的州长声明我能找到的只有在报纸和几个电视故事中，它们似乎都来自沃克在这一切发生时所做的那个问答环节。
Joshua Inglett-- why did you decide to withdraw his nomination?
乔什·英格莱特——你为什么决定撤回他的提名？
We got plenty of other good candidates, and we're not going to get into specifics about it. We've made a decision in our office to withdraw the nomination, and we'll be submitting another student to be one of the regents.
我们还有很多其他优秀的候选人，我们不会陷入细节。我们办公室已经决定撤回该提名，我们将提交另一名学生担任董事之一。
Another reporter asks if Walker checks all candidates against the recall petition. Walker avoids saying what people in his office do. He just speaks specifically about himself.
另一位记者询问沃克是否检查了所有候选人的罢免请愿书。沃克避免说他办公室的人在做什么。他只专门谈论他自己。
I don't do anything in that regard, but in terms of that, like I said, my comment's just going to be that we went through the nominations.
在这方面我什么都没做，但关于这一点，就像我说的，我的评论只是说我们经历了提名过程。
So it wasn't because he signed the petition?
所以这不是因为他签了请愿书？
Again, as I said before, I'm not going to comment one way or the other.
同样，正如我之前所说，我不会评论任何一方。
The governor mostly repeats a vague line about how they don't want to, quote, "drag him through the details of that."
州长大多重复了一句模糊的话，关于他们不想，引用，“拖着他经历那些细节。”
You keep saying you don't want to drag him through, talking about this reason, but he is saying that he hasn't done anything wrong.
你一直说你不想拖着他，谈论这个原因，但他正在说他没做错任何事。
We're not saying there's anything-- all I'm saying--
我们不是在说有什么——我所说的——
That's indicating that he did something wrong.
那表示他做错了什么。
No, it didn't indicate anything. You're putting words in my mouth. I said we're withdrawing the nomination, and we'll be submitting another name from the wide list of students that we got.
不，这什么也没表示。你在往我嘴里塞话。我说我们正在撤回提名，我们将从我们获得的大量学生名单中提交另一个名字。
Josh Inglett is not the only case of this. There are other instances where the recall petitions are being used as a political enemies list-- a blacklist.
乔什·英格莱特不是唯一的案例。还有其他情况下，罢免请愿书被用作政治敌人名单——黑名单。
OK, Thomas Wolfgram, the judge from Ozaukee County who signed the Walker recall petition, is having now to explain why he signed that.
好的，托马斯·沃尔格拉姆（Thomas Wolfgram），来自奥索基（Ozaukee）县的法官，签署了沃克罢免请愿书，现在不得不解释他为什么要签那个。
During the spring of 2013, the same time Josh was interviewing with the governor's office, another situation was playing out in a judicial election. Wisconsin is one of the states that elects its judges. And at some point, a newspaper had run the names of judges through the recall database. It found 29 signed the recall petition.
2013年春天，就在乔什与州长办公室面试的同时，司法选举中上演了另一种情况。威斯康星州是选举法官的州之一。在某个时候，一家报纸把法官的名字通过罢免数据库进行了比对。结果发现29人签署了罢免请愿书。
Among the names, Thomas Wolfgram, a judge from Ozaukee County, one of the most conservative counties in the state. That spring, Wolfgram was up for reelection.
名字中包括托马斯·沃尔格拉姆，奥索基县的法官，该州最保守的县之一。那个春天，沃尔格拉姆要竞选连任。
This has now become an issue in that campaign because a young conservative attorney who is an extremely good candidate-- an Iraq war vet, former clerk for the Wisconsin Supreme Court-- is raising the issue.
这现在成了那场竞选中的一个问题，因为一名年轻的保守派律师，他是一名非常优秀的候选人——伊拉克战争老兵，威斯康星州最高法院的前书记官——正在提出这个问题。
What you're hearing is a talk show host in Milwaukee, Charlie Sykes. He was one of the conservatives who turned Wolfgram's signature into an issue. Sykes highlighted the story on air, explaining to listeners that Thomas Wolfgram had been exposed-- how he was this closeted Democrat living among the conservatives of Ozaukee County. And he explained how the judge with the signature had outed himself.
你听到的是密尔沃基的一位脱口秀主持人，查理·赛克斯（Charlie Sykes）。他是将沃尔格拉姆的签名变成一个问题的保守派之一。赛克斯在节目中强调了这个故事，向听众解释托马斯·沃尔格拉姆是如何被曝光的——他如何在奥索基县的保守派中间成为一个隐藏的民主党人。他还解释了法官是如何通过签名暴露自己的。
On the air, the judge is referred to as a, quote, "flaming liberal" and a "unionista," among many other things. One of these segments also showcased the judge's challenger, a Tea Party backed lawyer named Joe Voiland, who had decided to run against Wolfgram after finding out about the recall signature. In this audio you're about to hear, the host of the show, Charlie Sykes, speaks first.
在广播里，这位法官被称为，引用，“激进自由派”和“工会分子”，以及其他许多事情。其中一个片段还展示了法官的挑战者，一名叫乔·沃兰德（Joe Voiland）的茶党支持的律师，他在发现罢免签名后决定与沃尔格拉姆竞选。在接下来你将听到的这段音频中，节目主持人查理·赛克斯先发言。
He's never actually stepped forward and said, I signed it because I wanted to throw Scott Walker out of office. I signed it because I'm a liberal, pro-union Democrat, and I wanted to overturn the 2000 election.
他从来没有真正站出来说，我签它是为了把斯科特·沃克赶下台。我签它是为了我是一个自由派、支持工会的民主党人，我想推翻2000年的选举。
Well, he put his John Hancock on that piece of paper, and your signature-- your John Hancock-- is who you are and what you stand for. Now, look. The judge in his private life supported lawlessness. The recalls were about lawlessness and selfishness, and lawlessness and selfishness are two things that a judge should not support.
好吧，他在那张纸上签下了他的名字，而你的签名——你的名字——就是你是谁和你所代表的东西。现在，听着。法官在他的私生活中支持非法行为。罢免是关于非法和自私，而非法和自私是法官不应该支持的两件事。
In reality, Thomas Wolfgram, the guy being called lawless-- he made a career as a criminal prosecutor, first as an assistant DA, then as a deputy district attorney.
实际上，托马斯·沃尔格拉姆，这个被称作非法之徒的人——他的职业生涯是一名刑事检察官，先是担任助理地区检察官，然后是副地区检察官。
And I eventually ran for and was elected district attorney here in Ozaukee County.
我最终竞选并当选了这里奥索基县的地区检察官。
And what were you running as?
你作为什么身份参选的？
I ran as a Republican.
我作为共和党人参选。
A few things to know about the guy being lampooned as a lawless, pro-union flaming liberal, other than the fact that he's a former prosecutor and a Republican. Wolfgram was originally appointed to the bench by a Republican governor. And once he was on the bench, people liked him. In 2008, Wolfgram was named Judge of the Year by the Wisconsin State Bar Association.
关于这个被讽刺为非法、支持工会的极端自由派，除了他是前检察官和共和党人这一事实之外，还有几件事要知道。沃尔格拉姆最初是被一位共和党州长任命到法官席位上的。一旦他坐上法官席，人们就喜欢他。2008年，沃尔格拉姆被威斯康星州律师协会评为年度法官。
Given his reputation and his record, when the signature thing hit, a lot of people rallied to the judge's defense. He was endorsed by every police chief in his county, the county sheriff, the Deputy Sheriffs Association, a number of district attorneys, prominent private attorneys, other state judges, state Supreme Court justices. On talk radio, these people were simply referred to as Wolfgram's, quote, "courthouse cronies."
鉴于他的声誉和记录，当签名事件爆发时，许多人聚集起来为法官辩护。他得到了县里每一位警察局长、县警长、副警长协会、众多地区检察官、著名私人律师、其他州法官、州最高法院法官的背书。在谈话电台中，这些人被简称为沃尔格拉姆的，引用，“法院走狗”。
So this campaign went on for months. And remarkably, during that time, the challenger, Voiland-- he actually never criticized any part of Wolfgram's nearly two decades on the bench.
所以这场竞选持续了几个月。值得注意的是，在这段时间里，挑战者沃兰德——他实际上从来没有批评过沃尔格拉姆近二十年来担任法官的任何部分。
To my knowledge, no one ever questioned my criminal sentencing practices, my decision making in civil or family law cases. They never quarreled with my judicial demeanor. It was limited to one issue-- that I had signed a recall petition.
据我所知，没有人质疑过我的刑事量刑标准，我在民事或家庭法案件中的决策。他们从未对我的司法风度提出异议。仅限于一个问题——我签署了罢免请愿书。
Joe Voiland, the lawyer who ran against him-- he told me, yeah, that's true. He actually never had any problems with how Wolfgram did his job. But he said Wolfgram's signature permanently compromised his ability to be seen as fair and impartial.
乔·沃兰德，那个和他竞选的律师——他告诉我说，是的，那是真的。他实际上从来没有对沃尔格拉姆如何完成工作有任何问题。但他表示，沃尔格拉姆的签名永远损害了他被视为公平公正的能力。
Wolfgram, for his part-- he told me he'd signed the petition not as a political statement about Walker's policies, but because he thought the public wasn't given enough time to digest the policies. That's what made it traumatic for the state. This is actually something Walker later said himself.
沃尔格拉姆本人——他告诉我说，他签请愿书不是作为关于沃克政策的政治声明，而是因为他认为公众没有足够的时间消化这些政策。这正是让该州感到痛苦的原因。这实际上是沃克后来自己也说过的话。
But so for months, Joe Voiland sounded the alarm in speeches, on the internet, on the radio, in mail to voters. Wolfgram's signature had tainted him. Wolfgram went on to lose by a landslide-- by more than 25%.
但几个月来，乔·沃兰德在演讲、互联网、广播、给选民的邮件中敲响警钟。沃尔格拉姆的签名让他蒙羞了。沃尔格拉姆最终以超过25%的巨大劣势败选。
After Wolfgram lost, the head of the Republican Party in his county wrote an editorial for the local paper. The title was, "Calling a Spade a Spade." Quote, "A big thank you is in order to all the Democrats and liberals who signed the Recall Walker petition. As was clearly shown in our election for judge, the signed petitions will be utilized as an effective tool to determine the most viable candidates for future elections."
沃尔格拉姆失败后，他所在县的共和党负责人为当地报纸写了一篇社论。标题是，“直言不讳”。引用，“要对所有签署罢免沃克请愿书的民主党人和自由派人士说一声大大的感谢。正如我们在法官选举中清楚地表明的那样，签署的请愿书将被作为一种有效的工具，来确定未来选举中最可行的候选人。”
He says Wolfgram's huge defeat is a warning, not just to people who signed the petition, but to people who support anyone like that. It's a not so veiled threat to people who stood up for Wolfgram-- people like the Republican county sheriff and the Republican district attorney. Essentially, he says, look out. We're coming for you next.
他说，沃尔格拉姆的惨败是一个警告，不仅是对那些签署请愿书的人，也是对那些支持任何像他这样的人的警告。这对那些站出来支持沃尔格拉姆的人来说是一个不太含蓄的威胁——比如共和党县警长和共和党地区检察官。本质上，他说，小心点。下一个轮到你们了。
I talked to one of the bloggers who first outed Josh Inglett for having signed the recall. He's a young conservative named Brian Sikma. He told me, while Governor Walker's office doesn't say whether it checks who signed the recall, he said, frankly, he finds the idea that they don't check-- he called it far-fetched. And if somehow they didn't know before Josh Inglett that bloggers and activists would look at each and every appointment they make and call people out, Brian Sikma says he hopes they learned a lesson-- that outing people like this is now just standard procedure.
我和最早曝光乔什·英格莱特签署罢免书的博主之一谈过。他是一个叫布莱恩·西克马（Brian Sikma）的年轻保守派。他告诉我，虽然沃克州长办公室不说是否检查了谁签署了罢免，但他表示，坦率地说，他发现他们不检查的想法——他称之为牵强。如果沃克州长办公室在乔什·英格莱特之前不知道博主和活动家会查看他们所做的每一项任命并公开批评人们，布莱恩·西克马说他希望他们吸取了教训——像这样曝光人们现在只是标准程序。
Sure. Well, there are district attorneys, assistant district attorneys. We found some judges. We also found people that serve on the judicial ethics board. Candidates for school board would probably be about the lowest rung that would be checked and would end up in the public debate, as far as during an election.
当然。嗯，有地区检察官、助理地区检察官。我们找到了一些法官。我们还发现了服务于司法道德委员会的人。学校董事会候选人可能会是最低的一级，在选举期间作为公共辩论的一部分会被检查。
People in the past may have been left to wonder, well, whose side are they on politically? But now with the recall petition database, we can go in there, enter their name, and we can get some idea, some perspective as to whether or not they would be siding with Governor Walker, or whether they may not be using their position to slow down the governor's agenda, or at least have a certain perspective on an issue being debated in the state right now.
过去的人们可能对他们在政治上站在哪一边感到疑惑，但现在有了罢免请愿数据库，我们可以进去，输入他们的名字，我们可以得到一些想法，一些视角，关于他们是否会站在沃克州长一边，或者他们是否可能不会利用他们的职位来拖慢州长的议程，或者至少对该州目前正在辩论的问题有一定的看法。
In terms of the environment this has created within Wisconsin politics, I had a pretty telling conversation with a Republican staffer. The staffer told me Josh Inglett's story in particular made him worried, because, he said, he saw himself in it. He'd also signed the recall petition. Actually, he signed it the day after Josh did.
就这在威斯康星政治中创造的环境而言，我和一位共和党工作人员有过一次颇具代表性的谈话。这位工作人员告诉我乔什·英格莱特的故事时特别担心，因为，他说，他在故事里看到了自己。他也签署了罢免请愿书。实际上，他在乔什签署的第二天就签了。
The staffer's mother was a teacher, just like Josh's mom, and the staffer had signed the recall as a Christmas present to her. This person, who we'll keep anonymous for obvious reasons, says he was really afraid that someone would find out about his signature. And he worried it wouldn't just be embarrassing for him, but it could hurt his boss and his boss's standing within the Republican Party-- make it harder for both of them to do their jobs. Describing what this time was like, he said he was seeing people, quote, "exposed and publicly shamed nearly every week." He said, quote, "I lived in fear."
这位工作人员的母亲是一名老师，就像乔什的妈妈一样，这位工作人员签署罢免是为了作为给她的圣诞礼物。此人，我们出于显而易见的原因保持匿名，说他非常害怕有人发现他的签名。他担心这不仅会让他感到尴尬，还可能损害他的老板和他的老板在共和党内的地位——使他们俩都更难完成工作。在描述那个时期是什么样时，他说他看到人们，引用，“几乎每周都被曝光和公开羞辱。”他说，引用，“我生活在恐惧中。”
What do you feel like this has taught you about politics?
你觉得这让你对政治有了什么了解？
I guess there's always a larger game that's at play.
我想总有一场更大的游戏在进行。
For his part, Josh Inglett's reaction to all this-- to his name being withdrawn-- wasn't to get mad at all. When reporters came calling, Josh says he was honest, and his honest reaction was to accept what was happening, not to retaliate or point fingers.
就乔什·英格莱特而言，他对这一切的反应——他的名字被撤回——根本没有生气。当记者来访时，乔什说他是诚实的，他诚实的反应是接受正在发生的事情，而不是报复或指责。
Not to show any hatred towards the governor, but to show compassion and love, I guess. Not to reject them, but to be supportive. And it was not a time to act childish or to be yelling and kicking and screaming and pouting because of what had happened.
不要对州长表现出任何仇恨，而是表现出同情和爱，我想。不要拒绝他们，而是要给予支持。现在不是孩子气、大喊大叫、又踢又跳、发脾气的时候，因为所发生的一切。
Was that at all hard to do? Were you feeling that way?
这样做很难吗？你有那种感觉吗？
No, that was something that I've always been raised to do. When I played quarterback in high school, that was what I had always done. When you play quarterback in Portage, you don't win very many games, but you always take the blame for things.
不，那是我一直以来被教育要做的事情。当我在高中打四分卫时，那就是我一直做的事情。当你在波蒂奇打四分卫时，你赢不了多少比赛，但你总是承担责任。
And when you win, it's always the line. The line is the reason that you won the game, and you are the reason that you would lose the game. Credit the line for your wins, and take the blame for your losses.
当你赢球时，总是锋线队员的功劳。锋线是你赢球的原因，而你是你输掉比赛的原因。为胜利归功于锋线，并为失败承担责任。
Josh says maybe it was advice from his dad, the Lutheran minister, or from his mother, who had always encouraged him to send personal thank you notes. Which that was actually something Josh did in this case, including one to the governor's office, who he told if they ever had any positions in the future, and he could be helpful, he'd still love to serve.
乔什说也许那是他父亲，路德宗牧师的建议，或者来自他母亲的建议，她总是鼓励他寄送个人的感谢信。这实际上是乔什在这个案件中做的事情，包括给州长办公室寄了一封，他告诉他们如果将来有任何职位，他能帮忙，他仍然很乐意效劳。
Given this experience that you've had, if you had the chance to take that signature back, would you do it?
鉴于你所拥有的这段经历，如果还有机会收回那个签名，你会这样做吗？
No. I wouldn't. I still love my mother, and there's no reason that I should waver away from my love for my mother due to politics like that. That's not something that should interfere there.
不。我不会。我仍然爱我的母亲，没有什么理由让我因为那样的政治而动摇我对母亲的爱。那不是应该干涉的事情。
So for the Walker administration, if you're looking for somebody who agrees with your politics, who's a fan of yours, and who's still excited to serve, but who won't sell out his mom, for your consideration, Joshua Inglett. He says you've got his cell number.
所以对于沃克政府，如果你正在寻找一个赞同你政治观点、是你的粉丝、并且仍然热衷于服务的人，但他不会出卖他的母亲，供你考虑，约书亚·英格莱特。他说你有他的手机号码。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "PERMANENT RECORD" BY THE GOLDEN DOGS]
[音乐 - “永久记录” (PERMANENT RECORD) - 金狗乐队 (THE GOLDEN DOGS)]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Dana Chivvis.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔 (Jonathan Menjivar) 制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格 (Alex Blumberg)、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·凯尼格 (Sarah Koenig)、米基·米克 (Miki Meek)、布莱恩·里德 (Brian Reed)、罗宾·塞米恩 (Robyn Semien)、艾丽莎·希普 (Alissa Shipp) 和南希·厄普戴克 (Nancy Updike) 参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德 (Julie Snyder)。制作协助来自达娜·奇维斯 (Dana Chivvis)。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
塞斯·林德 (Seth Lind) 是我们的运营总监。艾米莉·康登 (Emily Condon) 是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森 (Elise Bergerson) 是我们的行政助理。阿德里安·马蒂韦茨 (Adrianne Mathiowetz) 运营我们的网站。
Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis. Research help by Michelle Harris and Julie Beer.
今天的音乐协助来自达米恩·格拉夫 (Damien Graef) 和罗伯·格迪斯 (Rob Geddis)。研究协助由米歇尔·哈里斯 (Michelle Harris) 和朱莉·比尔 (Julie Beer) 提供。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia, who explains how he got the nickname Lollipop.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚 (Torey Malatia)，他解释了他是如何得到“棒棒糖”这个昵称的。
I got involved in a fight, and I licked the guy pretty good.
我卷入了一场打斗，我把那个家伙修理得很惨。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台 (PRI)。